[Music]
hi so i'm chalota fraza and i'm doing my
second year of my phd right now in
computational neuroscience in the
netherlands so i wanted to show you
today a little bit of what my day
actually looks like so from waking up to
programming all the things and then
hopefully if you're thinking of doing a
phd in this field this will give you a
little bit an indication of what it
looks like so my phd is related to
psychiatric disorders so i'm looking at
different psychiatric disorders and we
want to find these kind of biomarkers
from for example genetic or brain data
and hopefully i hope that in the future
these kind of models will really help
people that are suffering from several
psychiatric disorders such that they
don't have to go through all the
clinical trials beforehand or such that
we can really recommend for the
individual a personalized program as to
how to get help or which medicine works
best so i hope you enjoy and see you
next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you